a lot of you watch my cogent well-argued
attack on Wolverines claws and you said
lighten up man you're taking it too
seriously it's just a comic book shame
on you you need to ask a little bit more
of your entertainment you need to ask
for scientific accuracy Ben Fraser
rights you tried to use the logical
argument in a universe where there are
Russians made of metal Blue Demon
carnival freaks and a girl that sucks
out your soul those make perfect sense
compared to bone claws Jason Phillips
rights bones could grow it's called
evolution do you read or go to school
well I've got to brush up on my Stephen
Jay Gould but I don't think evolution
accounts for a man sprouting bone claws
from his arm I'll go back and
double-check that but that doesn't sound
like good science to me that doesn't
sound like good science fiction to me a
lot of you wrote in to note that there
actually is a species it breaks its bone
and six them out of its body the hairy
frog however go back and look at my
video I mentioned mammals specifically
Wolverines a mammal no mammal has non
keratin claws and besides if the Marvel
people knew about this creature why did
they call him Wolverine why didn't they
call him hairy frog now in my video I
invited you all to join the angry nerd
army and welcome aboard everyone who
enlisted I especially want to welcome
Mikhail kosenko who writes is there a
KGB division in the a na no there is no
secret police division in the angry nerd
army absolutely not thanks for watching
keep commenting and record response
videos to me if you don't like what you
hear me say or if you just want to tell
me how right I am there's a lot of stuff
I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them